[Music]
in waste of time news waste of time
submitted by high-five clammy what's
what's me for that I got clammy like
kind of little it's not bad oh dude your
claim is yeah Jax off all the time
because he has natural luminous blobs I
make the best sushi ever because I add
flavor to my rolls when you make sushi
you got some sweaty ass sushi dude what
that's why you love my musubi spam is
the hand Fandral very good I'm chillin
Hawaiian thing yeah a school made eighty
students taking alcohol test over one
empty beer can of course wow you think
that's the worst thing that they do oh
my god
what about the rape begun to meet the
[ __ ] benches in school which is a
real thing I remember we did a like few
articles on that [ __ ] under bench under
Ben Tre you know those [ __ ] like high
school bleachers yeah yeah that prom
night rape yeah what about that [ __ ] huh
know if my own son raped a girl in high
school and she said no I will go down
the bleachers and rape him this to me is
just like the Justice Department going
after marijuana people it's like Jesus
guys this slippery slope thing they're
like oh one can was in now there's just
gonna be [ __ ] humongous handles of
vodka everywhere so they gotta find that
guy yeah how can you catch like a person
that just drink you get Makem
breathalyzers so this school which is in
New Jersey they found a single beer can
tumbles and hits the feet of two
administrators and so that's when the
one
them he walked over to where the group
of students were and said that either
they fess up who brought that beer can
into the football game or they would
have everyone be tested with their blood
and their urine what well everybody's
get caught then that's really invasive
blood yes and they're saying that if if
you don't get tested then you will be
slapped with a five day suspension if
you don't agree to it
all of the people in the stadium are
gonna be suspended so I turned out to be
about 80 students and lots do not go to
school for five days sure I'll take that
yeah why suspension like a bad thing a
full suspension we used to have that
it's gonna sound then yeah that's words
dude odd campuses special was the
[ __ ] worse dude you got to stay there
not say [ __ ] they make you work on stuff
that you don't have to work on and that
should be suspension yeah and my OCS too
when it was [ __ ] hot they'll be like
oh you guys can be disruptive shut the
a/c off and we would just sweat to death
in there yeah cuz for me suspension was
always like oh my god vacation I should
do I should do this more like I get to
stay home play video games and when you
think business so it kind of sucked
Oh school I just watch TV all day
there's bad for your college application
though that's what it did they give you
those do they even know that you've been
suspended I'm pretty sure it's in the
records oh yeah if you want to transfer
directly via to a four-year university
yeah they're gonna look it up if they
got choose between you and someone else
they got that I thought they just got
you like your GPA and all that stuff I
didn't know and I never got suspended so
no really we're all bad kids they're
sorry for stupid [ __ ] dude I bought an
n64 off someone and then a Nintendo 64
all right it's game talk
it was stolen you know and I bought it
for like a hundred bucks all someone
knowing that it was stolen
nobody knew was gone yeah buddy no was
that big of a deal you know some some
sweet kid has [ __ ] they took my money
right and then I got suspended because
they told on me after that well game I
remember well they found out that it was
gone and then they found out that he
sold it and then he ratted me out that I
bought it and I got suspended for buying
it yeah how the [ __ ] do they track the
n64 no because kids its kids have loose
lips that's why that's true not a single
one from one of the faculty members
that's why they were drinking at it they
like but these kids so one by one they
had the students leave the bleachers
each row at a time go into the school
and then in the school they gave these
students a notice which then they gave
to their parents saying that they had to
these parents have to take these
children within the next two hours to go
to a hospital to get their blood drawn
and have their urine tested and make
sure that they weren't intoxicated so
eighty students and parents were you
mean they were so pissed because now
they have to waste time to go to
different hospitals all these hospitals
were bombarded with students all these
teenagers like why do we have to test so
many kids and then apparently a lot of
parents were charged to do these
testings so who's the [ __ ] genius
that decided to make this like move like
move forward with it like what the [ __ ]
someone had to come up with the idea was
one of the administrators he's like
we're cracking down like that conscious
dumbass because I would be like you know
there is laws and you're violating a lot
I would just sit that would [ __ ] that I
would just have one of the faculty
members everybody before you leave this
place breathe on somebody's face how how
about the dude when I was in high school
we would find like condoms in the field
and [ __ ] like during PE because during
the night some homeless people decided
to [ __ ] there or whatever or like some
kids [ __ ] there or something but like
that doesn't mean that we the kids that
were at school at the time
did that [ __ ] but the beer can't rolled
onto their feet yeah oh that's true all
that testing out of those eighty
students they found less than five kids
that were intoxicated and some of these
kids arrived at the game already drunk
that's [ __ ]
they shared a [ __ ] beer this big five
kids myth and they're drunk what a bunch
of losers if I just have been the last
one that they had bunch of lightweight
yeah were their parents there it's a
game right so there's so they stopped
the game - yeah they stopped the game
but one parent was saying that he she
took her son to go watch the game and so
she went with him and so she said that
she had to see her son be forced to go
sit with students and then if those were
the students that got caught up on all
this and then he/she had to go and have
her son get tested so she was like what
the [ __ ] I want to watch this game with
my son waste my time [ __ ] booth I'm
mad that I [ __ ] your [ __ ] wait
so you can't bring alcohol to a high
school game nah there's no wait
, you can't bring alcohol to a high
school game I just pictured like a dad
like drinking beer watching the game
with his kids that's what dads hate
going to that [ __ ] that's why dads by
flash that's why my dad never came to
anything I was in because he couldn't
drink there right oh yeah kaziri - yeah
yeah why don't you have to be a
cheerleader
cuz she wasn't sure okay I think she was
in football weren't you and she's like
no that's [ __ ] then winning the
lottery find a woman who was playing
football yeah so anyways the school were
saying that they were just enforcing
policy cuz that's something that they
had to do but it just caused a lot of
controversy administrators like people
that like the town voted on these school
administrators so I feel like they're
definitely gonna lose their position
[ __ ] it
I'm just picturing like every time
something stupid as [ __ ] happens in a
school there's always some idiot with a
power trip that's been waiting for this
moment and it backfires like crazy on
them it's like if the mall cop got to
search everyone at the mall for someone
yeah he's like nobody's leaving and
everyone just walks by wait nobody's
leaving I said nobody's leaving it's
over but he wishes
I like the mall cops they just don't
give a [ __ ] you sit there how you doing
buddy and he's already jeez coming
through how's it going man just goes
yeah you do your job so yeah just garden
the hot dog on a stick
how about that go home I put a gun in my
mouth every night yeah but they are
saying that it is a little law that the
law does require school officials to
send students out to be tested whenever
their suspicions that they're under the
influence of like a state law or what
state is this do we not New Jersey glad
we have this law man oh it's good
we need this law I'll fight to protect
this law it makes me worried about
putting kids in school in public school
because there's just so many [ __ ]
morons running it and it's like is my
kids IQ gonna drop by like a few points
by going to these schools do you think
they would have better people running
schools if they get got paper
maybe next year like Isaac going to
school and doing all that [ __ ] you know
what happened to it from my knees like
my um my nephew's taught her how to do
mental math for some algebra [ __ ] or
whatever and then so she took the test
and she got a zero because they wanted
her to use a calculator to graph some
[ __ ] but they were off by a few points
because she rounded it off in her head
but she got a zero for it and then it
was like the teacher was wrong because
they couldn't compute it like it's like
the common core [ __ ] it's a
showing the paper how much whatever the
values you just answer booklet and said
nope and I was like dude what [ __ ]
that's how stupid the teachers are today
like I don't know I think it's about
following instructions probably okay
he'll monitor right I do a lot of stuff
this school is about it's not even about
the subjects and do you think dad's
about follow instructions in your
homework being a part of this machine
yeah that's what it is
powers was a hall monitor in elementary
school or anything but you were the girl
that everybody looked at throw rocks at
class but I would just be like hey go to
class I know I know a [ __ ] pen and a
piece of paper it would just be like go
to class and just to put in perspective
I was a nerd and I was still throw rocks
at you you see your bathroom pass you to
cop
use a burner of a teacher who had like a
bathroom pass it was like [ __ ] a surf
[Laughter]
with a key what's the point of it I
don't know I think they're the kids lose
that [ __ ] yeah but then you just gave me
a weapon and you just threw me in the
hallway with a [ __ ] like bludgeon
weapon
it's always something big like that like
a big flag or something hey guys would
you think of that video I know you loved
it so make sure to hit that like button
to watch more videos and check out up
here
[Music]
you